foreign
[Music]
Airport
I don't know a couple weeks ago a few
weeks ago maybe all right I want to give
you things to notice on your next trip
because otherwise it's just a drag to go
through and TSA and everything just some
things to notice and to think about you
mean things like we've become a slovenly
country that looks like we're going to
the damn bathroom in the middle of the
night when we travel put some clothes on
people real clothes no they got their
pajamas on because they want to sleep on
the plane cut them some slack no no no
so here you go so the first thing you
know at the at the TSA you got the the
X-ray machine right you got the X-ray
machine okay I just want to alert you of
something if there was a day and I'm old
enough to remember before anything got
x-rayed you know why because nobody had
an x-ray machine to do it and in the
1960s there was a Spate of of hijackings
many of them were to Cuba because we
didn't we our diplomatic ties have been
broken off uh and because the Cuba were
like they were commies right they were
sympathizers with the Soviet Union and
they were in our Hemisphere and so we
didn't have planes to Cuba so if someone
wanted to get fly to Cuba they had to
hijack a plane so I don't mean to laugh
but the hijackings to Cuba were like
common so Congress said we got to stop
this the only way we can do it is maybe
we can x-ray your luggage okay
so does anyone have an x-ray machine
that we can just drag in here and do
this right that's not so large like you
find in the hospital oh yeah
astrophysicists of the early 1970s
had just miniaturized
x-ray detectors to put into satellites
to observe the universe in the X-ray
part of the spectrum because black holes
and and matter swirling in down the
throat of a black hole just before it
goes to die radiates X-rays and we we
calculated this and we knew this and we
said we're going to find black holes in
the universe we needed an x-ray
telescope well the X-ray machines are
huge we have then we got to make them
smaller to fit into the into the the the
order the orbiting satellite and so a
company called American Science and
Engineering based in Cambridge
Massachusetts okay
pioneered small x-ray detectors and then
they got tapped by the government and
say will you bring those into every
airport in the country every
International Airport and thus was born
x-ray detectors at airports because of
astrophysicists
were any were any of these
astrophysicists also hijacking planes
because I can see a connection oh the
conspiracy theories oh yes and one of
the leaders of that was a guy named
Ricardo giaconi and uh he was also a
professor uh a scientist up at the
Harvard College Observatory the
Smithsonian astrophysical Observatory
today it's just called the center for
astrophysics and when I was an
undergraduate there I worked in his
group the X-ray group we did some things
all right and he would later be given
the Nobel Prize
for pioneering x-ray opening up an
entire new window on the universe x-ray
astronomy so and another cool thing is I
would later be tapped by the White House
to serve on a committee to to give out
the presidential medal of science okay
and this is under the George W bush
white house so I'm there and we get
invited to the ceremony so I'm ready to
enter the White House and he's oh we we
awarded to him he'd already gotten the
Nobel Prize dude give him the
presidential medal of science okay right
so exactly so he's coming into a little
bit of a letdown right I know I know but
so he comes in I and he's going through
this there's this this house you have to
walk through before you get to the White
House and that's where all the security
measures are so he's walking through and
I can't help but notice the White House
is using an American Science and
Engineering x-ray detector which this
guy invented it was his company it's his
company
we have come full circle here there it
is that that's so funny is like the guy
who made the thing that you're using for
security is the Ultimate Security risk
because he wouldn't know what because he
knows all the back doors if there is any
because he invented he knows what yeah
exactly
if you're using his machine he'll know
how to buy his own around anything in
his own inventions you know if if he had
come to the White House and I was head
of security I'd been like nah get that
guy up against the wall full pat down
cavity search that's right everything we
got to make sure this guy knows how to
hide stuff Lead Me
So anyway so when you go through the not
asne detectors anymore but that was the
birth of that entire movement and it was
astrophysicist serving our needs
happened to also serve the needs of the
government by the way I retell that
story uh in my book
um accessory to war the unspoken
alliance between astrophysics and the
military and more broadly it's between
astrophysics and security hey I'm
Adrienne solgard and I reinvented the
suitcase I love to travel but I can
never stay organized you know when you
get to your hotel you open your suitcase
and everything goes everywhere that's
why we created the carry-on closet a
revolutionary suitcase that keeps you
organized on the go the carry-on closet
has a patented built-in shelving system
compression straps to save space and an
even One Time Magazine best inventions
of the Year oh and for every suitcase
sold we saved 229 plastic bottles from
going into our ocean learn more at
soulguard.com
so Chuck so the interesting thing about
x-rays we think of them as penetrating
through objects right special kind of
light energy yes
it's not as weird as you think okay okay
you realize
visible light
penetrates glass
okay
that's why windows are made of glass uh
okay I mean listen I know that that was
a scientific stretch but uh okay but but
wait a minute but let's let's keep going
here do you know
that glass
blocks x-rays
and high energy light
okay all right now we're doing something
so not all substances are transparent to
all bands of light
that's all I'm trying to say I got you
okay so microwaves which is what your
phone use to communicate right they
clearly pass through walls because when
you go indoors you can still use your
cell phone I mean unless of course you
have Sprint I mean
yeah exactly I'm roaming in the kitchen
but not in the living room what okay so
so microwaves past the walls that are
otherwise opaque to you so the fact that
x-rays go through like luggage and
things and human flesh uh you know you
know what x-rays don't really go through
they don't really go through your bones
I was about to say why don't you if you
really want to fool an x-ray just make
everything out of human bones no no no
no no no no so it doesn't does not go
through bones so Bones cast a shadow on
what it is they're trying to view ah so
really what you're you're not seeing the
bones you're not seeing the bone you're
seeing the fact that the X-ray went
everywhere else except the bones exactly
so it's like when you stand in front of
the Sun and you do a puppet you know on
the ground a shadow puppet yeah it's
really just the you know the it's not
the image of your hand it's the absence
of your hand correct it is it it is it
is
you're giving meaning to the absence of
sunlight right where your hands had
blocked the photons in the sand right so
that's what's happening okay yeah yeah
yeah and so that's cool
uh discovered x-rays and he put his hand
in front of it and he saw that they're
the he saw the bones he could barely see
the flesh because it went right through
his flesh okay when you're looking out a
window you're not looking at the window
you're looking at what's beyond the
window okay so he's looking at he
doesn't see the he sees the bones
because the x-rays were absorbed by the
bones and he also think I saw his
wedding ring or something which absorbed
even more X-rays and that was like pitch
black rather than sort of grayish and
please do not ask why his wedding ring
was made out of human bone
he's a weird kinky
Manhattan luncheon in fact in all the
rest of the world they call rotten
generates rather than x-rays
um but ah yeah yeah yeah so uh point is
uh x-rays are useful for looking through
your luggage and finding things that you
might make a weapon out of typically out
of metal
but they will not find
weapons made out of things that are not
metal and are otherwise transparent to
plastic like
um a plastic gun right if you make a
plastic gun it's not it's not going to
find it in the same way it would reveal
a a metal gun so here's what you can do
now controversy on that too about
printable guns correct correct so here's
an interesting thing you can do
uh like like you said like I noted
um the bone does not completely block
the x-rays it just blocks more x-rays
than your flesh does so it casts its own
mild shadow in the photograph okay
if you have different frequencies
of light
and you interplay them
you can see
what the trend line is in the things
attempt to absorb it or not
and once you do that you're better at
detecting what could be in the suitcase
if you move the frequencies back and
forth but what they also do is they
attach color
this is the literal use of false color
whether you attach a color to the edges
of signals that are shown up in the
image in the X-ray image because your
eye picks up color much better than it
picks up tiny changes in in a grayscale
shadings all right so if I say anything
grayer than this level make it red and
anything less gray than that make it
blue your eye boom I see red and blue as
two completely separate things rather
than as the Continuum that it is so the
folks back there the TSA they have a
fascinating task ahead of them to
identify objects and shapes and and and
and highlight them in ways that it makes
it easy for the person looking through
your looking at your luggage rather than
harder yeah yeah that's that's super
cool and I wonder did they assign a
special color uh to sex toys because
they tend to somehow find them all the
time I've never seen this ever happen is
this you trying to pull sex stories
through the security is this I'm just
saying I don't know how every time you
never heard that this happens
that somehow they're just like gotta
check that one and it's just like nope
just another sex toy sorry everyone
everything's great
oh good no reason to be alarmed just
another tech sex story girl you're free
to go with your sex toy
uh and by the way those the those flappy
things at the entrance where your
luggage into the machine yes they're
like have heavy metal particles in them
so the X-ray is no correct so don't
reach in there because it's trying to
Shield you from the x-rays that would
otherwise uh leak out of that hole nice
there you go
well that is super oh I I have to tell
you I will never look at the X-ray
machine again the same and I want you to
think of astrophysicist when you do I
and I I will now which I have never done
before
it I can say that with x-rays are just
another band of light that comes to us
from the depths of space that humans on
Earth with excellent engineering has
exploited for all manner of social
cultural geopolitical purposes look at
that thank you Bill him okay all right
Chuck that's all we had time for this
explainer okay x-rays in the universe
and x-rays at the airport Chuck always
good to have you uh Neil deGrasse Tyson
here finishing up yet another explainer
before star talk as always keep looking
up
thank you